pues son miles de personas las que he
podido ver aquí en París en esta
movilización que ya ha hecho a andar
desde hace un poco más de 45 minutos
También tenemos reportes de lo que está
sucediendo en las demás regiones del
país porque hay más de 320
manifestaciones en toda Francia y lo que
tenemos hasta ahora como reportes Es que
la movilización es bastante importante
Esto es lo que se estaba buscando el día
de hoy especialmente bloquear el país
con la refinerías que están todas en
huelga en el día de hoy no hay ningún
tipo de salida de camiones con
combustible en la refinerías que sea
Total que sea exon esto en todo el país
aún hay una de ellas que es una de las
más importantes que de hecho ya anunció
que continuará esta huelga
indefinidamente y eso es también lo que
están buscando los sindicatos que estas
que esta huelga pues no sea solamente el
día de hoy sino que se prolongue lo más
pronto posible y lo más largo posible
para por fin digamos que la calle
aquellos que están en la calle los
manifestantes sean escuchados por el
gobierno